D
AFTERNOON INTO OUR OUR FELLOW
AMERICANS OUT WEST GOOD MORNING.
WE JUST COMPLETED TWO DAYS OF
MEETING THE WHITE HOUSE
CORONAVIRUS. TASK FORCE AND
PLEASED TO BE JOINED BY MANY
MEMBERS OF TASK FORCE WITH US
FOR THIS BRIEFING ONE OF THANK
SECRETARY- HR. DOCTOR BURKS
WITH DOCTOR FELT SHE DR REVEAL
THE CDC AS WELL AS OUR ATTORNEY
GENERAL- DR GERARD. ON THE US
PUBLIC HEALTH SERVICE. DR HANS
ZIMMER- BUT WILL MAKE A SERIES
OF PRESENTATIONS TO UPDATE THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE. ON THE STATUS
OF THE CORONAVIRUS PANDEMIC. IN
THE COUNTRY AND THEN BE
AVAILABLE TO QUESTIONS ABOUT
WE- VERY MUCH APPRECIATE OF THE
ATTENDANCE OF ALL WHO ARE HERE
AND ALL OF YOU WHO HAVE. THE
TIME TO TUNE IN. AS WE REPORTED
TODAY WE HAVE NOW MORE THAN.
TWO MILLION FIVE HUNDRED
THOUSAND AMERICANS. THAT HAVE
CONTRACTED THE CORONAVIRUS. AND
SADLY WE LOST MORE THAN A
HUNDRED TWENTY THOUSAND. OUR
COUNTRY THIS DISEASE. AND I
KNOW I SPEAK FOR THE PRESIDENT
FOR EVERY AMERICAN WHEN WE
EXPRESS OUR SYMPATHIES AND OUR
DEEPEST CONDOLENCES TO ALL THE
FAMILIES WHO HAVE LOST. LOVED
ONES. DESPITE THOSE LOSSES ON A
SINCE THE END OF OUR FORTY FIVE
DAYS TO SLOW THE SPREAD AND THE
BEGINNING OF EFFORTS TO. OPEN
UP AMERICA. THANKS TO THE
COOPERATION OF THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE. THE EFFORTS OF
GOVERNORS AND STATE HEALTH
OFFICIALS. EFFORTS I WANT TO
PROUDLY SAY OF. THE TIRE
FEDERAL TEAM UNDER THE
LEADERSHIP OF PRESIDENT TRUMP
NO WE HAVE NOT MADE A TRULY
REMARKABLE PROGRESS IN MOVING
OUR NATION FORWARD. WE'VE ALL
SEEN THE ENCOURAGING NEWS AS WE
OPEN UP AMERICA GET MORE THAN
THREE MILLION. JOBS CREATED IN
THE LAST JOB REPORT RETAIL
SALES ARE ROLLING- AND OF
COURSE THE EXTRAORDINARY
PROGRESS IN NEW YORK NEW JERSEY
CONNECTICUT AND NEW ORLEANS
AREAS THAT. A JUST A MATTER OF-
OF A MONTH AGO WELL WE'RE
STRUGGLING UNDER THE WEIGHT. OF
THIS PANDEMIC AND- THE NOW
HAVE- ARRIVED AT A VERY VERY
DIFFERENT PLACE. WE STAND TODAY
ALL FIFTY STATES AND
TERRITORIES ACROSS COUNTRY ARE.
ARE OPENING UP SAFELY AND
RESPONSIBLY. BUT WITH. AS IN.
PARTICULAR OVER THE PAST WEEK
THROUGHOUT THE SOUTH. PRESIDENT
TRUMP- DIRECTED OUR TASK FORCE
YOU BRIEF THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
ON SEVERAL TOPICS FIRST WE WANT
TO SHARE WITH YOU IS DOCTOR
BURKS WILL. BUT WHAT WE'RE
SEEING IN THE RISE OF NEW
CASES. FOR THAT TODAY
SURROUNDED FORTY THOUSAND. NEW
CASES IN A SINGLE DAY. A SECOND
LATER WE WANT TO SPEAK ABOUT
WHAT WE'VE DONE AND WHAT WE ARE
DOING AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL TO
SUPPORT. EFFORTS PARTICULARLY
THE STATES FOR RECEIPT. AS IN
CASES BUT WE'LL TALK TODAY
ABOUT ABOUT HOW THIS MOMENT IN
THE CORONAVIRUS PANDEMIC IS
DIFFERENT. THAN WHAT WE SAW TWO
MONTHS AGO. THE TO BETTER EQUIP
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE TO RESPOND.
AN ALTERNATELY WE WILL SPEAK
ABOUT WHAT EVERY AMERICAN CAN
DO TO PLAY THEIR PART- ENOUGH.
IN REDUCING THE SPREAD. AND THE
IMPACTS OF THE CORONAVIRUS OF
PANDEMIC. OF FOR OUR PART ALSO
I'M I'VE SPOKEN TO GOV PERSON
ON- IN IN FLORIDA AND TEXAS THE
IMPLANT. TWELVE HOURS. INVERTER
BROOKS WILL BE TRAVELING ON
SUNDAY TO TEXAS OF. DATE THIS
WEEK TO GET A GROUNDER IN
COURSE ON THE ON WE WILL-
CONDUCT WHAT WILL BE OUR TWENTY
SIXTH WEEKLY CALL WITH THE
ENTIRE WHITE HOUSE CORONAVIRUS
TASK FORCE IN ALL OF ELECTIONS
GOVERNORS AS WE AS WE NEED
SMALLMAN. AS I IT'S IMPORTANT A
GATHERING GATHERING TODAY I
THINK THAT WE TAKE A TAKE A
STEP BACK AND THINK ABOUT HOW
FAR WE'VE COME. AS A COUNTRY.
WITH PRESIDENT TAPPED ME TO
LEAD THE WHITE HOUSE
CORONAVIRUS TASK FORCE HE SAID
WE HAVE ONE MISSION. AND THAT
WAS TO SAVE LIVES. PRESIDENT
TRUMP'S DECISION TO SUSPEND ALL
TRAVEL FROM CHINA IN JANUARY TO
STAND OF THE WHITE HOUSE
CORONAVIRUS TASK FORCE.
FEBRUARY TO DECLARE A NATIONAL
EMERGENCY TO HAUL TRAVEL FROM
EUROPE AND AMEND TRAVEL FROM
OTHER PLACES AROUND THE COUNTRY
ALL CONTRIBUTED TO- GIVING OUR
NATION. TIME TO STAND UP A
BROAD BASED RESPONSE OF. THE
WHOLE OF GOVERNMENT RESPONSE
THAT- WE SPOKE ABOUT SO MANY
TIMES. AT THE PODIUM THROUGHOUT
THIS PANDEMIC- WITH THE STATE
DEPARTMENT ALSO COORDINATED THE
REPATRIATION OF NINETY FIVE
THOUSAND. AMERICA AND THEN CAME
THE MOMENT WHEN WE BROUGHT THIS
DARK. TO THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES. ON THE COUNCIL
OF OUR VERY BEST SCIENTISTS THE
PRESIDENT WAS PRESENTED WITH
THE DECISION THAT IF WE DID
NOTHING NO INTERVENTION.
POSSIBILITY EXISTED AT THAT
MOMENT IN TIME THAT WE COULD
LOSE BETWEEN ONE POINT FIVE
MILLION AND TWO POINT TWO
MILLION AMERICANS BUT WITH
INTERVENTION AND WITH
MITIGATION. FOR CALLING ON THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE. TO EMBRACE THE
MITIGATION EFFORTS SOCIAL
DISTANCING OTHER WERE CALLED
UPON FIRST IN THE FIFTEEN DAYS
TO SLOW THE SPREAD THAT WOULD
BECOME FORTY FIVE DAYS TO SLOW
THE SPREAD. ARVEST SCIENTISTS
BELIEVE THAT WE COULD WE COULD
REDUCE THE NUMBER OF AMERICAN
FATALITIES TO A NUMBER RANGING
BETWEEN ONE HUNDRED AND TWO AND
FORTY THOUSAND. THE PRESS MADE
THAT DECISION- END WE UNVEILED
THE FIFTEEN DAYS THAT BECAME
THE FORTY FIVE DAYS TO SLOW THE
SPREAD. AND IN ARGUABLY AS WE
SEE WHERE WE ARE TODAY AS A
NATION BECAUSE OF WHAT THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE OF ON BECAUSE
OF THE INCREDIBLE WORK OF OUR
HEALTH CARE WORKERS BECAUSE ON
A PARTNERSHIP WITH GOVERNORS
AND AT LEAST. WE DID THAT WE
SLOW THE SPREAD FLATTEN THE
CURVE WE SAVED LIVES IN THE
MIDST OF THAT WE EXPONENTIALLY
SCALE TESTING CAPACITY
PARTNERING WITH PRIVATE SECTOR
OF COMMERCIAL LABORATORIES-
WE'VE WE'VE NOW REACHED A SOME
THIRTY MILLION PROTESTS ACROSS
THE COUNTRY CONDUCTING SOME
FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND TEST A
DAY. THE PARTNERSHIP WITH
GOVERNORS ALSO PRESIDENT
DIRECTED US TO MAKE SURE THAT
STATE'S HAD WHAT THEY NEEDED
WHEN THEY NEEDED. AND AT THIS
POINT. PLEASE REPORT THAT THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT BOTH
DELIVERED AND FACILITATED THE
DELIVERY OF BILLIONS OF
SUPPLIES OF. OF FACE AND GOWNS
AND GLOVES AND MASKS AND WE
CONTINUE TO BE ON TRACK. TO
CONSTRUCT MORE THAN A HUNDRED
THOUSAND VENTILATORS IN A
HUNDRED DAYS AND- AND AS AS I
SPOKE TO GOVERNORS LAST NIGHT
THEY CONFIRM TO ME AGAIN. BUT
FAMOUS REPORTED THAT WE HAVE NO
OUTSTANDING- FROM ANY STATE AT
THIS TIME. FOR A PROTECTIVE
EQUIPMENT OR MEDICAL SUPPLIES.
LET ME SAY THAT AGAIN IN THE
AFFECTED AREAS PARTICULAR LEADS
DOWN SET PRODUCING RISING CASES
WE HAVE WHILE STANDING PRESS.
BUT AS I THE OWNERS READY MOM
THIS THE SEARCH PERSON TO
SEARCH. BECAUSE TO. JUST THE
HAVE IS IT THE MIDST OF THE I
IT ALWAYS BEEN SAYING THAT
BECAUSE OF. THE WORK OF OUR
HEALTH WORKERS BECAUSE AMERICAN.
NO AMERICAN WHO REQUIRED AT A
LATER. HAS EVER BEEN DENIED A
VENTILATOR IN THE UNITED
STATES. AND I'D GO I CONSIDER
THAT NOTHING SHORT. OF A
NATIONAL ACCOMPLISHMENT. WE
ALSO SURGED HOSPITAL CAPACITY
IN AREAS WITH THE GREATEST
ANTICIPATED NEED. WE SEND
MILITARY NATIONAL GUARD.
PERSONNEL AND- THESE CHARTS
SHOW THE PROGRESS THAT WE'VE
MADE IN NEW YORK. AND EACH IS A
AND- THEY- MEANWHILE OPERATION
WITH FEDERAL GOVERNMENT ALL THE
GREAT HEALTH CARE WORKERS SHOW
THE PROGRESS THAT WE'VE MADE IN
AREAS THAT WERE ONCE. DEEPLY
IMPACTED- AND WE EXTEND OUR
THANKS- WE EXTEND OUR THANKS TO
THE PEOPLE OF EACH STATE'S FOR
THE SACRIFICE. THAT THEY MADE
DURING THE REAGAN ON TIME. BUT
AT THE CLOSE OF THAT THREE FIVE
DAYS TO SLOW THE SPREAD WE
UNVEILED. A PLAN TO. SAFELY RE
OPEN AMERICA YEAH NOW ALL FIFTY
STATES AND TERRITORIES ARE
MOVING FORWARD AND AS I SAID
WE'RE SEEING AMERICA GO BACK TO
WORK. IN MY PUBLIC THREE WERE
WE'RE SEEING A JOB SIX.
ECONOMIC ACTIVITY EXPANDED. BUT
OUR FOCUS TODAY IS VERY MUCH ON
ON THE ADVENT OF RISING THE-
NEW CASES ACROSS. IN SOUTH. IN
BUT WHERE OUR FIRST WAS TO SAY
LIVES. WE CAME OUT OF THE FORTY
FIVE DAYS TO SLOW THE SPREAD OF
WHAT OUR TASK FORCE HAS BEEN
FOCUSED ON OVER THE COURSE OF
THE PAST TWO MONTHS. ORDER WITH
STATE TO SAVE LIVES AND SAFELY
RE OPEN IN FACT WE'VE- WE'VE
HAD- SOME SEVENTEEN MEETINGS AT
THE WHITE HOUSE CORONAVIRUS
TASK FORCE IN THE INTERVENING
DAYS SINCE WE BEGAN THE PROCESS
OF OPENING UP AMERICA AGAIN AND
WE'VE BEEN WORKING VERY SHOULD
THE STATE. TO MOVE THAT AGENDA
FORWARD. DOES THE PRESIDENT
MADE CLEAR WE WANT TO OPEN OUR
ECONOMY UP AND WE WANNA MOVE
AMERICA FORWARD EVEN WHILE WE
TAKE AND CONTINUE TO TAKE THE
STEPS NECESSARY TO PROTECT
LIVES AND THE HEALTH OF THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE. WE STAND HERE
DAVE WAS WITH THE WITH THE
RISING CASES AMONG SOUTHERN
STATES PRESIDENT TRUMP PASSED
US TO BRIEF THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE. TO GIVE DETAILS ON WHAT
WE'RE SEEING WHAT WE'RE DOING.
AND HOW IT'S DIFFERENT FROM TWO
MONTHS. AS YOU MAY RECALL.
AFTER SAYING OVERALL CASES
DROPPED FROM A THIRTY THOUSAND.
A DAY AVERAGE IN APRIL TO.
TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND A DAY OVER
AVERAGE IN MAY THE FIRST FEW
WEEKS OF JUNE. ACTUALLY SAW
CASES EVER GETTING ROUGHLY
TWENTY THOUSAND NEW CASES TODAY
WE NOW. HAVE IN CASES BEGIN TO
RENT RISE PRECIPITOUSLY ACROSS
THE SOUTH. IN FACT. THIRTY FOUR
STATES- THIRTY FOURS. FOR ME
MAKE SURE I GOT MY NUMBERS
EXACTLY RIGHT HERE. AS WE
REPORTED EARLIER ON THIRTY FOUR
STATES ACROSS THE COUNTRY
THOUGH. ARE EXPERIENCING A
MEASURE OF STABILITY THAT IS A
CREDIT TO ALL THE PEOPLE OF THE
STATE. AND WHEN WE SPEAK ABOUT
A STABILITY WE ARE TALKING
ABOUT NOT NECESSARILY SPEAK FOR
THEIR NEW NEW CASES. BUT THESE
WOULD BE STATES WHERE THEY'RE
EITHER NO NEW CASES AND RISING
FOR THE GEORGE COMBINATION OF
THOSE TWO THINGS. THERE STATES
ACROSS THE COUNTRY THAT ARE
SEEING A MODEST INCREASE IN
CASES. BUT THEIR PERCENTAGE OF
POSITIVE RACES REMAINING VERY
STEP. AND BUT NOT THERE ARE
SIXTEEN STATES WITH RISING
CASES AND RISING PERCENTAGES
AND- WE'LL BE FOCUSING ON THE
STATE'S TODAY FIRST THING WOULD
SHARE WITH THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
IS THAT. WHILE THERE IS A
PENSION- IT IN THE NATIONAL TO
USE A BROAD BRUSH IN TWO OF. IF
IT IS IN CASES IN A PORTION OF
THE STATE THIS IS ACTUALLY A
BETTER PICTURE OF THE DATA THAT
WE LITERALLY ANALYZE EVERY
SINGLE DAY. DR BURKS WILL TAKE
A FEW MOMENTS- TWO OF UNPACK.
THE FIRST THING WE WOULD
CONVEY. TO THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
IS THAT- FROM THIS OF NEW
POSITIVE RESULTS IN THE LAST
THREE DAYS YOU CAN SEE THE
CONCENTRATION OF NEW CASES IN
SPECIFIC PARTS OF STATE. AND OF
COURSE- VERY POLICE IN PARTS OF
COUNTRIES OF THE PARTS OF THE
COUNTRY. PEOPLE UNDERSTAND IT'S
JUST AN ARGUABLE THAT MORE
TESTING IS GENERATING MORE
CASES. ONE EXTENT OR ANOTHER
BALL. THIS COMING. SUCCESS IN
EXPANDING TESTING ACROSS THE
COUNTRY AS I SAID AT THE TOP
WHERE TEN MORE THAN ACT OR SOME
FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND OF PEOPLE
A DAY AND WE COULD BE THERE TO
REFRESH THEIR JUSTICE SO. OF
THAT PLACE. OF THE PANDA. THE
UNITED THE TRUE A REMARKABLE
AND IT'S GOING TO PUBLIC AND
PRIVATE PARTNERSHIP OF FROM
FROM THE VERY OUTSET. ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT WE'RE SEEING
AMONG THE K. AS IN WE HEAR THIS
IN FLORIDA- THIS IN TEXAS AND
ELSEWHERE. IS THAT ROUGHLY HALF
OF THE NEW CASES. ARE AMERICANS
UNDER THE AGE OF THIRTY FIVE
WHICH- WHICH IS AT A CERTAIN
LEVEL VERY ENCOURAGING NEWS.
THE EXPERTS TELL US BECAUSE AS
WE KNOW SO FAR IN THIS
PANDEMIC. THAT YOUNGER
AMERICANS ARE LESS SUSCEPTIBLE
TO SERIES OUT COPIES OF THE
CORONAVIRUS AND- THE FACT THAT
WE ARE FINDING MORE. YOUNGER
AMERICANS. DRAFTED THE
CORONAVIRUS. IS A GOOD THING.
AND SO WILL- WE'LL SPEAK ABOUT
THE TESTING AND REGRET YOUR R.
IS HERE- AND CAN YOU TELL ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MIGHT HAVE ABOUT
TEXTING FOR. THIRDLY TALK ABOUT
WHAT THESE ARE THESE NEW
NUMBERS MEAN AND HOW WE CAN
ADDRESS DR. PEOPLE SPEAK ABOUT
THAT IN JUST A MOMENT
PARTICULARLY IN THE AFFECTED
AREAS. AND OF THE OTHER AREAS
WE SPEND A GREAT DEAL OF TIME
THINKING ABOUT IS. HOSPITAL
CASE EVERY DAY. CAN COUNTY
BASES BUT WE ALSO TRACK
HOSPITALIZATION AND- THE MAP ON
THE LEFT OF YOUR SCREEN
REPRESENTS HOW. SOME HEALTH
CARE WORKERS HAVE THE RESOURCES
AND SUPPORT THEY NEED AGAIN AS
IN THE AS IN THE MATTER OF NEW
CASES YOU CAN SEE WITH HOSPITAL
AND- IT'S HOT FOCUSED HIGHLY
DETAILED. AND HIGHLY SPECIFIC.
SECTOR IS OUR WILL SPEAK ABOUT-
HOSPITALIZATION THE WORK OF HHS
TO MAKE SURE THAT- ARE
HOSPITALS AROUND THE COUNTRY
HAVE THE CAPACITY TO. MEET THIS
MOMENT OF BUT- AS DR BIRCH MAY
WELL REFLECT AS WELL WE ARE
ENCOURAGED THAT. WE'RE TWO
MONTHS AGO WE WERE SEEING SO.
PERCENT OF NEW BASES THE LAW
NOW THE NUMBERS ARE ROUGHLY 5%
ON THE- WHICH IS ALSO ENCOURAGE
NEWS. AISLE SAY THE LEAST. AND
SO THE ARM. UP WHILE WE OF WHAT
WE HAVE SIXTEEN STATES THAT
WE'RE FOCUSING ON AGAIN I WOULD
JUST REITERATE THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE THE MOST USEFUL THING TO
KNOW IS WHERE IT'S HAPPENING.
SO THAT YOU CAN TAKE THE STEPS
NECESSARY TO DO MORE. REST
ASSURED IN OUR CONVERSATION.
WINNERS IN ALL THE MOST
IMPACTED THE STATE'S A WE
CONTINUE TO BE SURE THE
HOSPITAL CAPACITY REMAINS
STRONG- IN THEY KNOW THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT STANDS
READY. TO PROVIDE THEM WITH
PERSONAL PROTECTIVE. OR
SUPPLIES OR EVEN EXPAND
CAPACITY AND PERSONAL TO ME AT
ANY MOMENT BUT- AT THIS POINT
IN TIME WE ARE TOLD TO THEY
DIDN'T IN ALL THE STATES MOSTLY
IMPACTED THE POSITION EVERY.
VERY BROADLY AVAILABLE. FINALLY
I WANT TO SPEAK ABOUT THE
PROGRESS THAT WE'VE MADE AS A
COUNTRY. ON THE MOST DIFFICULT
ACT OF THIS. I SAID BIG- THAT
OUR HEARTS AND OUR PRAYERS. GO
OUT TO THE FAMILIES WHO LOST
LOVED ONES IN THE COURSE OF THE
CORONAVIRUS PANDEMIC MAN I KNOW
I SPEAK ON BEHALF OF. OF
EVERYONE IN THIS COUNTRY WHEN I
EXTEND OUR SYMPATHIES TO THE
MORE THAN A HUNDRED AND TWENTY
SIX THOUSAND FAMILIES THAT HAVE
LOST LOVED ONES. THIS IS AN
MANY TIME ONE LIFE LOST IS TOO
MANY. BUT BUT NEVERTHELESS WE-
I BELIEVE AT THIS POINT IN THE
COURSE OF THE PANDEMIC. WE CAN
STILL TAKE SOME COMFORT IN THE
FACT THAT- FATALITIES ARE
DECLINING. ALL ACROSS THE
COUNTRY THEY'RE LITERALLY WAS
A- A DAY TWO MONTHS AGO THIS
WEEK WHERE WE LOST TWO THOUSAND
FIVE HUNDRED AMERICANS IN A
SINGLE DAY. THIS WEEK BECAUSE
OF THE EXTRAORDINARY WORK OF
OUR HEALTH CARE WORKERS.
BECAUSE THE AVAILABILITY OF NEW
MEDICINE FOR HIM DOES APPEAR
NEW TREATMENTS LIKE SPARE PARTS
IN BECAUSE OF THE COOPERATION.
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE. NEWS THAT
WE GAVE AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL
STATE AND LOCAL OFFICIALS GAVE.
THIS WEEK- THERE WERE TWO DAYS
WILL BE LOST LESS THAN THREE
HUNDRED AMERICANS. AND YOU CAN
SEE FROM. WHAT HAS BEEN A
PRECIPITOUS DECLINE FROM SOME
OF THE WORST MOMENTS OF THIS
PANDEMIC IS IMPACTED THERE IS
OF. YORK NEW JERSEY AND
NORTHEAST. I HAVE A HEAVY HEART
ANYTIME I RECITE THESE NUMBERS
BUT- BUT THE FACT THAT WE ARE
MAKING PROGRESS- REDUCING THE
NUMBER OF AMERICANS THAT WE
HAVE LOST AND ARE LOSING I HOPE
IS AN AND- BECAUSE AS WE SEE
NEW CASES RISING AND WORK
TRACKING VERY CAREFULLY THERE
MAY BE A TENDENCY. THE PEOPLE
THINK THAT WE ARE WE ARE BACK
TO THE PLACE THAT WE WERE. TWO
MONTHS AGO. THAT THAT WE'RE IN
A TIME OF GREAT LOSSES AND- A
GREAT HARDSHIP ON THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE. THE REALITY IS IN A
MUCH BETTER PLACE WITH THE-
WITH THE EVER PRESENT TRUMP
BLASTED THE- WITH THE EFFORT
THIS TEAM. HOLD GOVERNMENT
APPROACH PERCENT PERCENT THREE.
CREDIBLE YOUR- AND- AMERICAN
WE'RE REPLACED THE TRUTH IS WE
DIDN'T WE FOR THE WITH ABLE TO
STAY UP THE- AND CAPACITIES IN
OUR HEALTH CARE SYSTEM TO BE
ABLE THIS OF OUR- IT WOULD PUT.
ON THE HEALTH ALL OF OUR
COUNTRY FIRST BUT WE ALSO WE
ALSO CARED FOR THE MOST OF ALL.
DID YOU DEVOTE RESOURCES AND
TESTING AND SUPPLIES. ON THE
MOST VULNERABLE CITIZENS IS
UNDERLYING CONDITIONS. TO
BELIEVE ALL MY HEART THAT WE'VE
CONTINUED. TO SAVE LIVES WE
CREATED A SOLID FOUNDATION FOR
WHATEVER CHALLENGES COME EITHER
IN THE DAYS AHEAD OR IN THE
MONTHS AHEAD. AND THAT'S A-
THAT'S A CREDIT I BELIEVE TO
OUR PRESIDENT TO OUR FEDERAL
TEAM TO OUR STATE PARTNERS.
WE'LL SEE IT'S A PRESS. BOTH
AND ARE HEALTH CARE. AND WE
HERE TODAY WE BELIEVE WE'VE
MADE PROGRESS- BUT AS WE ARE
REMINDED AS WE SEE CASES
RISING- ACROSS THE SOUTH- THAT-
WE STILL HAVE WORK TO DO. AND
SO WE SAY TO EVERY AMERICAN.
PARTICULARLY THE IN COUNTIES
AND STATES THAT ARE BEING
IMPACTED BY RISING CASES OF
THAT- NOW IS THE TIME FOR
EVERYBODY TO CONTINUE TO DO
THEIR PART. AND I THINK YOU'LL
HEAR FROM THIS PODIUM TODAY A
PARTICULAR MESSAGE TO YOUNGER
AMERICANS. YOUNGER AMERICANS
ACROSS THE SUNBELT ON THE ROLE
THAT YOU CAN PLAY. ATTACKING
THE VULNERABLE MAKING SURE THAT
WALL THE CORONAVIRUS DOESN'T
REPRESENT. AS SIGNIFICANT A
THREAT FOR SERIOUS OUTCOME FOR
TO A YOUNGER AMERICAN. NONE OF
US WOULD WANT TO- BRING THE
DISEASE BACK. TO OUR PARENTS OR
GRANDPARENTS MOMS AND DADS ON
AN ELDERLY FRIEND OR- A FRIEND
WHO HAS ON DEFICIENCY ON.
CAUGHT A SERIOUS. WE LEAVING
JUST THE GUIDELINES FOR ALL OF
THE FACES. WHEN WE PUT OUT THE
GUIDELINES OPEN OF AMERICA
AGAIN- WE LAID OUT AT- AT THE
OUTSET- GUIDE FOR RESPONSIBLE
REOPENING IN STATES ACROSS THE
COUNTRY AS I MENTIONED ARE
DOING JUST THAT. FORCED BASHAR
RE OPENINGS PLEA AND
RESPONSIBLY AND SEEING A LOW
END- STEADY CASES AND NOT
SAYING ARISE- IN THE PERCENTAGE
OF POSITIVES. AND IN THE
SIXTEEN STATES THAT ARE BEING
IMPACTED PARTICULARLY THOSE
THAT WILL FOCUS ON HERE TODAY.
WE WOULD JUST ENCOURAGE EVERY
AMERICAN. TO FOLLOW THE
GUIDELINES FOR ALL THE FISH
CONTINUE TO PRACTICE GOOD
HYGIENE WASH YOUR HANDS AVOID
TOUCHING YOUR FACE. DISINFECT
FREQUENTLY OF. PEOPLE WHO FEEL
SICK SHOULD STAY HOME AND WHEN
IT COMES TO BUSINESSES- SOCIAL
DISTANCING PROTECTIVE EQUIPMENT
TEMPERATURE CHECKS TESTING IN
ISOLATION- THESE ARE THE
GUIDELINES FOR ALL OF THE FACE-
THEY ARE GOOD PRACTICES TWO OF.
TWO MEN. UNITY THIS IS OR EVEN
IF YOU ARE NOT. BECAUSE WHAT IS
THE PROGRESS THAT WE MADE THAT
YOU SAW ILLUSTRATED IN THOSE
CHARTS IN PLACES LIKE NEW YORK
AND NEW JERSEY CONNECTICUT AND
NEW ORLEANS WAS- WAS A RESULT
OF THE- OF THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
STEPPING FORWARD HEEDING THE
GUIDANCE OF. THE FEDERAL STATE
AND LOCAL AUTHORITIES AND WE
ENCOURAGE YOU TO CONTINUE TO DO
JUST THAT. BUT THE FOR THOSE IN
THE AREAS MOST AFFECTED WE JUST
WANT TO ENCOURAGE YOU. TO
LISTEN TO AND RESPECT THE
GUIDANCE OF YOUR STATE AND
LOCAL AUTHORITIES. I RECOGNIZE
THAT THIS IS DIFFERENT THAN TWO
MONTHS AGO BOTH IN OUR ABILITY
TO RESPOND. AND IN THE NATURE
OF THOSE THAT ARE BEING
INFECTED AND THAT YOUNGER
AMERICANS THE PARTICULAR
RESPONSIBILITY TO MAKE SURE.
THEY'RE NOT CARRYING THE
CORONAVIRUS THE SETTINGS ARE
WHERE THEY WOULD EXPOSE THE
MOST VULNERABLE. END UP AND
LASTLY AS I PREPARE TO BRING DR
BIRCH OF THE PODIUM I JUST
ENCOURAGE EVERY AMERICAN
CONTINUED PRESS. FOR ALL THE
FAMILIES THAT HAVE LOST LOVED
ONES FREE FOR HEALTH CARE
WORKERS ON THE FRONT LINES. ON
THE JUST CONTINUE TO PRAY. AT
THE BY GODS GRACE EVERY SINGLE
DAY. WILL EACH OF US PART TO
HEAL OUR LAND. THAT OVERDUE
SUPPORTER OF THE WHITE HOUSE
EFFORT ON CORONAVIRUS DR
DRIVERS. THANK YOU MR VICE
PRESIDENTE- THANK YOU FOR THAT
GREAT INTRODUCTION ON JUST TO
REMIND EVERYBODY WHERE WE HAVE
COME FROM HIM THE LAST FOUR
MONTHS WE HAVE A GREAT DEAL OF
UNDERSTANDING NOW ABOUT THE
ORIGINAL DISEASE. DIFFERENT
WELL IN SNOW WE BELIEVE
EVERYBODY IS SUSCEPTIBLE TO
INFECTION. BUT WE KNOW
INFECTION LEADS TO A SPECTRUM
OF DISEASE WE HAVE MUCH BETTER
DETAILS ABOUT WHO IS VULNERABLE
AND WHY THEY ARE GONE ABOVE.
AND IT IS PRESIDENT AT ONE TIME
WE WERE DIAGNOSING PEOPLE IN
THE C. U. AFTER THEY CAME INTO
THE EMERGENCY ROOM. AND THANKS
LET ME ALSO BEEN EATING OUR
GUIDANCE THEY HAVE BEEN COMING
FORWARD IN GETTING TESTING AND
SO WHEREAS BEFORE WE TOLD HIM
TO STAY HOME. WE ARE TELLING
THEM TO BE TESTED AND THIS IS A
GREAT CHANGE FOR US BECAUSE IT
ALLOWS US NOW. TO FIND THEM TO
MATT AND THE MILEAGE THESE THAT
WE INVITE OF OUR- I STOPPED
READ TALKED ABOUT YES HEY FROM
THE SERVER. TESTS WE HAVE A
GREAT UNDERSTANDING OF WHAT WAS
HAPPENING IN MARCH. AND THE
NUMBER OF A SYMPTOMATIC AND
MILD CONDITIONS THAT LEAD TO
INDIVIDUALS TO HAVE ANTIBODIES.
BUT NEVER COME FORWARD WITH
SIGNIFICANT DISEASE. WE NOW
KNOW WHO IT RISK FOR
SIGNIFICANT DISEASE AND WE NOW
KNOW IT'S PARTICULARLY THE
ELDERLY INDIVIDUALS OVER AT.
AND INDIVIDUALS WITH
COMORBIDITIES AT MEMBER THOSE
COMORBIDITIES STAND THE ENTIRE
EIGHT THROUGH. WE DO KNOW THAT
WE HAVE PEOPLE IN THE YOUNGER
AGE GROUPS WAS SIGNIFICANT TYPE
ONE DIABETES. AND MAY ALSO HAVE
INDIVIDUALS WITH SIGNIFICANT
OBESITY WE KNOW THAT THOSE ARE
RISK FACTORS AND SO RISK
FACTORS GO WITH YOUR CO
MORBIDITY NOT NECESSARILY WITH
YOUR AGE. AND SO AS WE CALL ON
INDIVIDUALS TO PROTECT ONE
ANOTHER BY PASSING SOMEONE ON
THE STREET YOU DON'T KNOW WHAT
COLOR. THEY HAVE THIS IS WHY IT
IS STOP TRYING TO ACT ONE
ANOTHER. WE ARE AS FOR THE
ATTACK CAN BE THAT TABLE TO
CLINICAL CARE HAS DRAMATICALLY
IMPROVED. AND I WANT TO THANK
AND I H. WHO'S BEEN WORKING
CONSTANTLY TO UPDATE THE
CLINICAL GUIDELINES SO
POSITIONS AROUND THE UNITED
STATES AND FRANKLY AROUND THE
WORLD WHO ARE USING THOSE HAVE
THE MOST UPDATED INFORMATION
ABOUT AISLE TO ACTUALLY IMPROVE
DISEASE COURSES THOSE
INTERVIEWS THAT ARE IN THE
HOSPITAL. WE AND IN THREE AND A
HALF THAT WE HAVE IN AND MY BRO
WITH. OXYGENATE IS REALLY
IMPORTANT IMPROVE TREATMENT OF
ACUTE RESPIRATORY DISTRESS
THAT'S THAT THAT INDIVIDUALS ON
A VENTILATOR WE KNOW NOW WE'RE
RESPOND QUITE WELL TO STEROIDS.
AND THEN RESEARCH THAT IS
ONGOING ON WHAT WE CALL THE
CUTE CYTOKINE STORM AS WELL AND
I ON. IN THAT LATER STAGE WHEN
PEOPLE ON VENTILATORS THIS THIS.
ILL MAY NEED STEROIDS AND OTHER
ITEMS AND THAT'S BEING RESEARCH
THE WORK THAT'S BEING DONE
CLOTTING RESEARCH BY THE NIH.
WE ALSO IS THERE A FEW DAYS OUT
AND USE BOTH- COMPASSIONATE YOU.
CONVALESCENT PLASMA. AND OUR
DESK HERE THAT WOULD JUST BE
ALLOCATED AND ENSURED IT WAS
AVAILABLE TO THE STATES THAT
ARE FACING THE INCREASED COST
AS ASIAN AS WELL AS- MONTHLY
ALLOCATIONS THAT WE HAVE BEEN
SENT. YOU CAN GO TO THE FOR.
INSTANCE AT THE VICE PRESIDENT
LAUGHS LEFT OFF A REALLY.
DISEASES TACKLED COMMUNITY BY
COMMUNITY TESTING AT THE
COMMUNITY LEVEL AND WORKING
WITH COMMUNITY GROUPS TO
UNDERSTAND THE SPREAD IN THOSE
COMMUNITIES. AND SO EVENTS THE
TIME TO REALLY WRAP THIS
EPIDEMIC NEW POSITIVES DOWN TO
THE LEVEL OF COMMUNITIES TO
UNDERSTAND WHERE'S IS OCCURRING.
SO WE CAN MATCH. ENTER
INSTITUTE YES EXPIRE THESE. WE
DID DISCUSS DIFFICULT FOR YOU
TO SEE ON THE BIG THE TOP LINE
IT YORK AND WE REMEMBER WHERE
WE WERE AT THAT'S- THAT EARLY
SLOW BUT YOU CAN SEE AN ACE OF
THE- NEW YORK CASE THIS RAP.
SELLER SHIN ON THIS SLIDE CAN
SEE. ON CALIFORNIA THAT IS THE
BLUE LINE THAT IS JUST PASSING
R. LINE. SO ON THE SLOT IS
TEXAS IN GREEN FLORIDA AND
ORANGE. AND AT THE BOTTOM.
AFTER MATIC AS THE SLOPES ARE
THEY ARE NOT EQUIVALENT TO THE
AT REGIONAL ACCELERATION THAT
WE SAW IN NEW YORK THAT DOESN'T
MEAN THAT WE ARE ABSOLUTELY
FOCUSED ON WORKING WITH THE
GOVERNORS IN THOSE COMMUNITIES
TO STOP THIS IRISH IN THOSE
COURSES EIGHT. X. LIGHT PLEASE.
SHOWS YOU THROUGH. STATE BY
STATE OBVIOUSLY THIS ACCIDENT
IS VASTLY DIFFERENT THAN THE
ONE ON THE PRIOR SLIDE BECAUSE
THAT SLIDE INCLUDED ALL OF THE
CASES IN NEW YORK CITY BUT YOU
CAN SEE ON THIS THAT WE TALKING
VERY CLOSE THE NORTH ALONG
GAMES BEEN IN WITH CAROL
WORKING. THE STATE. FIND TO THE
CHANGES THAT. HELLO AS THE THAT
SAW CAROL AT THE NEXT LIGHT
I'LL JUST GO QUICKLY THROUGH
THESE SO YOU CAN SEE ON
OKLAHOMA IS AT THE BOTTOM OF
THE SLIDE NECK I. YOU CAN SEE
ON THIS LOT ON IDAHO AND OREGON
ON THOSE ARE THE ONES IN THE
LIGHT BLUE AND A DARK GREEN
WHERE YOU SEE AN INFECTION IN
THERE SLOW. THESE ACTIONS IS
UNDERSTANDING WHEN THEY OCCUR
AND WHY THEY OCCUR OUR CRITIC.
FOR UNDERSTOOD HOW TO PREVENT
THE SPREAD NEXT LIFE HELP THE
VICE PRESIDENT ABOUT AS WE
CREATE ALERTS THAT BRINGS
TOGETHER. WHAT WE TALKED ABOUT
I THINK THIS IS WITH THE
UNDERSTANDING OF. THE TWO WHICH
COPY K. C. THOSE STATE ON THERE
ARE SOME TO HAVE THE HIGH TEST
POSITIVE THAT CAN SEE AT THE
HIGHER. LEVEL OF THE- THIS.
THAT WE HAVE OKAY. BECAUSE THE
RISING NUMBER OF CASES AND THE
RISING TEST POSITIVE. THIS IN
THIS EXPLAINS THE EXTENT OF
COMMUNITY SPREAD IN STATES THAT
HAVE INCREASING CASES. FALLING
TEST PILOTS IT TELLS US THAT
THEY'RE GETTING IN TO THE
COMMUNITIES TO FIND THE A
SYMPTOMATIC CASE AND SO THESE
ARE THE THINGS WE PUT TOGETHER
TO UNDERSTAND THAT SURE LIKE IF.
SO THAT REALLY PUTS ON ONE
SLOW. THE STATE THAT WE HAD
THAT WE WERE TALKING ABOUT
ACROSS THE SOUTH WHERE WE HAVE
OUR GREATEST CONCERNS. THE TWO
TOP STATES WITH THE LARGEST
INCREASE IN TEST POSITIVE R.
TEXAS AND ARIZONA FOLLOWED BY
BUT THIS IS. CAROL ABOUT US JET
LOUISIANA. BUT WE'RE TRACKING
THEM CLOSELY AS WE LOOK AT THAT
INDIVIDUALLY. FINALLY NEXT
SLIDE. YOU CAN SEE ON THIS
SLIDE WE ARE TRACKING IN THIS
IS WHEN YOU HEAR ABOUT WE HAVE
A CERTAIN 2% OR THREE THAT I
THINK UNDER SPECIFIC ALERTS SO
DOESN'T MATTER THE SIZE OF THE
COUNTY WE'RE TRACKING THAT
INCREASE IN THE RATE OF
INCREASE A NEW CASE AT THE
COUNTY LEVEL. WE CURRENTLY HAVE.
THIRTY OUT OF THE THREE
THOUSAND AND ONE HUNDRED IN THE
UNITED STATES IN THAT CATEGORY
NEXT SLIDE. YOUR LEVEL THE
SHOWS YOU THE CASE POSITIVITY
BY THE METROS- IN THE NUMBER OF
TESTS THAT HAVE BEEN DONE NEXT
SLIDE. AND THEN THIS SHOWS YOU
SPECIFICALLY THE CHANGE OVER
TIME PASS POSITIVITY AND THE
URGES METROS WHERE WE HAVE
CONCERNS AND THIS IS OFTEN
PHOENIX HOUSTON DALLAS SAN
ANTONIO TAMPA ORLANDO MIGHT
REVERSE. CALIFORNIA AND LANDS
AT. SPECIALIZATION SO THAT WE
CAN WORK WITH THE STATES FOR A
COMPREHENSIVE INTEGRATED
RESPONSE NEXT SLIDE I KNOW YOU
MANY OF YOU WOULD BE INTERESTED
IN HOW HIGH THE CAT TEST
POSITIVITY RATE BECAME. IN
APRIL AND MAY WELL MARCH IN
APRIL SO THAT TOP LINE IS NEW
YORK CITY METRO AND YOU CAN SEE
IT REACHED 50% ON A SERIES OF
ITS PROMISE TWO WEEKS. EVERY
50% OF THAT'S WHAT I DID IT BUT
NINETEEN. YOU SEE. ON THE- I
MINNESOTA AND A WHOLE SERIES OF
INDIVIDUALS DETROIT IS THE
SECOND THE SECOND LARGE
MOUNTAIN NEXT LIFE SO QUICKLY
SHOW YOU HOW WE LOOK AT THIS AT
THE STATE LEVEL ON AND WORK
WITH THE GOVERNORS A LOCAL
HEALTH AUTHORITIES SO THAT
LARGE WHICH TESTING DEBT THE
NUMBER OF POSITIVES THAT ARE IN
THE LINE THE TOTAL NUMBER OF
CASES. IN IN THE BAR AND WHAT
THEN DROP. ON AND OTHER REST
RATE VISAS AND NEXT LIFE. THIS
MAN WE LOOK THAT LEVEL TO LOOK
FOR TWO IN THE SLOPE OF THE
NUMBER OF NEW CASES SO YOU CAN
SEE THE TOP COUNTY THAT HAS THE
LARGEST INCREASE IN SLOPING
CASES MIAMI DADE FOLLOW A BRAT
AND PALM BEACH ALL THE OTHER
COUNTY MUCH IN THAT CASE
INCREASE THIS. THAT'S THE FOCUS
OR IS IT ASKING BOMB WITH. INTO
SPECIFIC SITES NEXT SLIDE. THAT
ALL COMES TO KEEP THE SECRET
THIS GRAPHIC SO THE INDIVIDUALS
CAN UNDER WE CAN PRECISELY
WHERE AT THE RATE OF GROWTH IN
IS AND WHERE THE RATE OF GROWTH
IS OCCURRING ON BY CHEATING
OTHER BOXES. PLEASE YOU THROUGH
TEXAS BECAUSE IT'S SAME. NEXT
FIGHT. SO THEY SHOW YOU THE
EXACT SAME ♪GRAPHICS NOW SHOWN
FOR TAXES SHOWING I COULD
CONTINUE RISE IN THE DAILY
TASKS PERFORMED BUT ALSO EIGHT
DAYS IN THE TEST POSITIVITY THE
BLUE LINE. THROUGHOUT MAY AFTER
OPENING TEST POSITIVITY
CONTINUED TO DECLINE THEIR
TESTING INCREASED. IT WAS IN
THE LAST HALF WEEKS THAT WE SAW
THIS INFLECTION OF RISING TEST
POP TIVITY ALONG WITH RISING
TESTING BUT IT WAS THE INCREASE
IN TEST POSITIVITY THAT ALERTED
US ALONG WITH INCREASE CASE IS.
WAS BECOMING AN ALERT YOU CAN
SEE ON THE ROAD THIS EVERYTHING
IS- HEATMAP SO WHAT LANDS.
THOSE BUY. IN THE MIDDLE THAT
READ. THAT THE HEAT MAP SAY. IS
SHOWING THAT THIS HAD BEEN K.
AND RISING TEST POSITIVITY NEXT
SLIDE BUT EVEN IN TACT S. NEXT
SLIDE PLEASE. AND THIS GIVES
YOU A MAP OF TEXAS THIRD SHOWS
WHERE THE CASES ARE AND WHERE
THEY'RE RISING THEM US RAPIDLY
AND FINALLY I ON I'M JUST GONNA
GO ARIZONA VERY QUICKLY A LOT.
YES THE NEXT I. SAY TUITION
WE'RE SHOWING HERE WITH ARIZONA
RISING NUMBER OF TESTS BEING
PERFORMED BUT ALSO RISING TEST
POSITIVITY RISING CASES NEXT
LIFE. ARIZONA IS UNIQUE IN THEY
HAVE ESSENTIALLY ONE COUNTY
THAT IS PART EARLY REPRESENTED
BY THE DEPTH OF THE NEW CASES
AND THIS IS IN THE PHOENIX AREA.
CONNECT NEXT SLIDE SO THIS IS
CALIFORNIA. AND SO YOU CAN SEE
CALIFORNIA OVER THE LAST WEEK
HAS HAD THAT INCREASE IN TEST
POSITIVITY YOU CAN SEE THAT
DRAMATIC INCREASE AT THE END OF
THAT BAR IT BLUE LINE HELLO
STILL IN. POSITED TESTING
THAT'S BEEN DONE AND WE JUST
WANT TO THANK ALL OF THE
GOVERNORS AND ALL OF THE WORK
AT ALL THE LABORATORIES THAT
HAS ALLOWED US ALONG WITH HHS.
AFTER OUR WHO SURE THAT THE
SUPPLIES THERE TO REALLY
INCREASE THESE ON LINE. YOU
COULD SEE ANY OF THESE CASES
THESE AREN'T ON TIME I. THE
LAST FOUR WEEKS. BLACK YOU MAY
THE PRIMARY INFECTIONS RIGHT
NOW IN CALIFORNIA AT THE
HIGHEST LEVEL ARE IN THE AREA
BUT BECAUSE LA IS A LARGE
METROPOLITAN AREA NEXT SLIDE
YOU REALLY NEED THIS KIND OF
MORE OR- ON. THE SPECIFIC AT
LOCAL GRAPHIC TO REALLY SHOW
THAT IT'S ALSO INCREASING IN
THE CENTRAL VALLEY AND THIS
GIVES US THE ABILITY TO FOCUS
RESOURCES AMONG AGRICULTURAL
WORKERS TO IMPROVE TESTING AND
ISOLATION FOR THAT TURKEY COME
POSITIVE. THE TAPE THREE HOW
BEEN LOOKING AT DATA HOW WE
CONSOLIDATE THAT DATA AND THEN
MONDAY REPORTED OUT TO THE
GOVERNOR'S. WE HOPE OVER THE
NEXT WEEK TO BE ABLE TO HAVE
THIS DATA AVAILABLE IN REAL
TIME ON THE WHITE HOUSE WHEN
IT'S SAID THAT EVERYBODY ACROSS
THE COUNTRY CAN SEE WHAT THE
CASES ARE. BECAUSE WE WERE ON A
CALL. WE STARTED TALKING ABOUT
WHAT CAN WE SAID THE MOST
IMPORTANT THING THAT WOULD
CHANGE THE SPREAD AND I'M GONNA
TURN THAT UP BECAUSE I KNOW
TONY'S GONNA TALK ABOUT IS. DID
YOU BEHAVE AND I RESPECT ONE
ANOTHER SOCIAL DISTANCING
WEARING ASKIN AND BRING THAT
WE'RE PROTECTING THE MOST
VULNERABLE THAT BABY AND MOM
JET. AND I JUST. BY TAKING
AGAIN THE MILLENNIAL. AND YOU
KNOW DURING THE APPROACH WE
LOST A LOT OF THEM TO GO
FORWARD TO GET TESTING AND WE
SEE THOSE TESTING RATES REALLY
IMPROVING AT A UNDER FORTY AGE
GROUP THAT IS GOING TO BE
IMPOSED TO CAN. TOLERATE AMONG
FORTY AGE GROUP THE AGE GROUP
MOST LIKELY TO HAVE A SYMPTOM
EXPRESS AND BE SPREADING THE
VIRUS BUT NOT TO THAT AND THEN
I WANT TO MAKE IT I WANTED
ACTUALLY READING THE PIRATE. I
BUT THE KNOW THAT THEIR IF THEY
HAVE THEM AND NEED. IN ORDER
HAVE THAT. SIR WE WILL I THANK
THEM AGAIN COMING IN REALLY
ENRICH. TESTING THAT HAS BEEN
DONE IN THE UNDER FORTY UNDER
FORTY YEAR OLD AGE GROUP UNTIL
OUR OLDER POPULATION IF YOU OWE
MORE BEEN. NOEL OVER EIGHTY WE
ASK YOU ANY HOT SPOTS IN THE
STATE SENATE HAVING ENGINE
BASES TO CONTEST YOU SHELTER
MATCHES YOU CAN. I NEED YOUR
GRANDCHILDREN TO GO SHOPPING.
BERGSON THANK. SO I WANT TO
EXTEND JUST FOR A COUPLE OF
MINUTES SOME OF THE COMMENTS
THAT WERE MADE BOTH BY THE VICE
PRESIDENT AND BY DOCTOR BURKS
AND IT HAS TO. WITH THE STORY
THAT FOR FOUR GOALS. IS CLEAR
FROM THE MAPS THAT YOU SAW.
THAT THERE ARE CERTAIN AREAS OF
THE COUNTRY SO EAST TOWNS
CITIES REGIONS. THAT ARE DOING
VERY WELL THERE FOLLOWED BY THE
CENTER OPENING UP. IN APPROVE
IT HAS BEEN EFFECTIVE. HOWEVER
AS YOU CAN SEE WE HAVE FACED.
PROBLEMS IN CERTAIN AREAS NOW
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE MAP IT'S
VERY INTERESTING BECAUSE YOU
SEE SOME DARK PARTS OF THE MAP
AND SOME LIGHT PARTS OF THE
MAP. WE HAVE A VERY REGINA'S.
BUT HEAD ORIGINATING DOES NOT
MEAN THAT WE ARE NOT INTIMATELY
INTERCONNECTED WITH EACH OTHER.
SO WHAT GOES ON IN ONE AREA OF
THE COUNTRY ULTIMATELY COULD
HAVE AN EFFECT ON THE OTHER
AREAS OF THE COUNTRY. SO LET'S
TAKE A LOOK AT THIS PROBLEM
THAT WE'RE FACING NOW THIS
RESURGENCE OF BASES. I DON'T
THINK TIME ENOUGH AND WILL DAYS
JUDGE. AS YOU'RE OUT. MULTI
ELEMENTS THAT WENT INTO THAT.
YOU KNOW EVERYTHING FROM MAYBE
OPENING A LITTLE BIT TOO EARLY
ON SOME TO OPEN THE RIGHT TIME.
BUT NOT AT FAULT STEPS POLICE
THAT. TRYING TO. BUT THE
CITIZENRY FEEL THEY WANTED TO
DO THAT FOR NUMBER OF IS LIKELY
BECAUSE EVERYONE'S THE COMMON
FEELING OF BEING UP FOR SUCH
LONG PERIOD OF TIME SO WE'RE
NOT GONNA TAKE CLAIM WHEN CHINA
ANALYZE IT WOULD THERE IS THIS
VERY IMPORTANT ABOUT THAT A LOT
TO GET A MESSAGE TO THE COUNTRY
IN GENERAL. WHEN YOU HAVE OUT
OF TECH DISEASE IT'S A DANA.
PROCESS THAT IS GLOBAL SO
REMEMBER WHAT HAPPENED IN CHINA
AFFECTED US WHAT HAPPENED IN
EUROPE AFFECTED US. WHAT'S
HAPPENING HERE IS AFFECTING
OTHERS WE CAN'T GET AWAY FROM
THAT. IS INTERCONNECTED SO
THERE. IF WE ARE IN IN TO
CONNECT SOCIETY. LOOK AT THE
FACT ON WHAT OUR ROLE IS IN
TRYING TO PUT AN END TO THIS
WAS EVERYBODY WANTS TO END IT
EVERYBODY WANTS TO GET BACK TO
NORMAL EVERYBODY ONCE THE
ECONOMY TO READ ABOUT I THINK.
A PRETTY COMMON IN THAT. A
GIVEN SO WHAT CAN WE DO. WHAT I
THINK UPON TALKING TO A LOT OF
PEOPLE AND REFLECTING ON IT WE
HAVE SUCH AN UNUSUAL SITUATION
BECAUSE OF ALL THE DECADES.
THAT I'VE BEEN INVOLVED IN
CHASING INFECTIOUS DISEASES
I'VE NEVER SEEN ANYTHING THAT
IS SO PROTEAN STABILITY TO MAKE
SEEK. SIX NOT THERE'S NO OTHER
INFECTIOUS DISEASE. LOWS FORTY
OF THE PEOPLE SYMPTOMS TO SOME
MILD SYMPTOMS TO SOME HAVING
SEVERE SOME REQUIRING STAYING
AT HOME FOR WEEKS SOME GOING TO
THE HOSPITAL SOME GETTING
INTENSIVE CARE SOME GETTING
INTO BABY SITTING BENT IT IN
SOME KIND. SO THAT DEPENDING ON
WHERE YOU ARE IN THAT SPECTRUM
YOU HAVE A DIFFERENT ATTITUDE.
THE TICKET WAS BOUGHT. ANYWAY
WHO GETS INTO OR IS AT RISK OF
GETTING INFECTED TO A GREATER
OR LESSER DEGREE IS PART OF THE
DYNAMIC PROCESS OF THE OUTBREAK
AND I KNOW BECAUSE I CAN
UNDERSTAND. WHEN I WAS AT A
STAGE IN MY LIFE WHEN I SAID
WELL I'M INVOLVED WITH. SO I'M
ON A RISK I THINK JUSTIN THIS
IS SOMETHING WE'VE NEVER FACED
BEFORE. IS THAT RISK FOR YOU IS
NOT JUST ISOLATED TO YOU.
BECAUSE IF YOU GET INFECTED.
YOU APART INNOCENTLY OR
INADVERTENTLY. OF PROPAGATING
THAT DYNAMIC PROCESS ON THE
PANDEMIC. BECAUSE THE CHANCES
ARE. THAT IF YOU GET INFECTED
THAT YOU'RE GOING TO INFECT
SOMEONE ELSE. AND ALTHOUGH YOU
MAY FEEL WELL AND BECAUSE WE
KNOW IF YOU LOOK AT THE NUMBERS
THAT YOU'RE- LEAVE HERE LATER
ON. THE OVERWHELMING MAJORITY
NOW OF PEOPLE BEING INFECTED OR
YOUNG PEOPLE LIKELY TO BE THAT
YOU SEE IN THE- SENATE PAPER
OUT IN. JOINING THEM.
UNDERSTANDABLY NO BLAME THE
UNDERSTANDABLE BUT THE THING
THAT YOU REALLY NEEDS BE A-
THAT WHEN YOU DO THAT. ONE OF
THE- IF YOU BEEN DIRECTED. X.
SOME ELSE WHO CLEARLY WILL IN
FACT SOME ELSE WE KNOW THAT
HAPPENED BECAUSE THE REPORT.
ELEMENT OF THE VIRUS IF NOT
LESS THAN ONE SO PEOPLE ARE
AFFECTING OTHER PEOPLE AND THEN
ULTIMATELY YOU WILL IN FACT
SOMEONE WHO'S VULNERABLE THAT
MAYBE SOMEBODY'S GRANDMOTHER
AND FATHER UNCLE WHO'S A- THERE
OF. AGENTS ON RADIATION OR
CHEMO OR A CHILD WHO HAS
LEUKEMIA SO THERE IS WHAT I
CALL AND AGAIN I JUST WANT TO
BRING THIS OUT WITHOUT MAKING
IT SEEM THAT ANYBODY'S AT FULL.
YOU HAVE AN INDIVIDUAL ABILITY
TO YOURSELF. YOU HAVE TO DECIDE.
RESPONSIVE BECAUSE WE WANT TO
END. THIS OUTBREAK. REALLY END
IT AND THEN HOPEFULLY ONE OF
VACCINE COMES AND PUTS THE NAIL
IN THE COFFIN WE'VE GOT TO
REALIZE THAT WE ARE PART OF THE
PROCESS SO WHEN THE PRICE
PRESIDENT WENT BACK PULLING
BACK A COUPLE OF MONTHS AGO
WHEN WE SHOWED ABOUT. THE
SIDELINES SAFELY RE OPEN THE
COUNTRY WE'VE GOT TO MAKE SURE
WE DROP BACK A FEW YARDS AND
THINK ABOUT THAT. THIS IS POLL
JUSTICE THAT WE CAN BE EAT.
PART OF THE SOLUTION OF THE- SO
I JUST TO MAKE A PLEA WITH
PEOPLE WHEN THEY UNDERSTAND THE
STRESS THAT THEY'RE UNDER AS WE
TRY TO TACKLE. NOT ONLY THOSE
STATES. BUT THE LIGHT COLORED
PART. OF THE COUNTRY EVEN
THOUGH THEY'VE DONE WELL. ON
HIT BADLY LIKE NEW YORK AND
CAME DOWN. BUT THEY MAY NOT
HAVE GOT HIT BADLY AT ALL. THEY
ARE VULNERABLE IF WE DON'T
EXTINGUISH THE OUTBREAK SOONER
OR LATER EVEN ONES DOING WELL
ARE GOING TO BE VULNERABLE TO
THE SPREAD SO WE NEED TO. DO A
CAMP BECAUSE WE ALL GET
TOGETHER AND THE ONLY WAY WE'RE
GOING TO END IT IS BY ENDING IT
TOGETHER THANK YOU. SENATOR
STUFF THANK YOU ALL FOR JOINING
US HERE AT HHS TO UPDATE THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE I WANT TO BEGIN
BY THANKING EVERYONE AROUND THE
COUNTRY WORKING TO DEFEAT THIS
VIRUS ALL OF THE HEALTH CARE
PROVIDERS ON THE FRONT LAWN.
THOSE WERE REOPENED LET ME SAVE.
AMERICAN PEOPLE WHO HAVE
SACRIFICED SO MUCH IN THIS
FIGHT AND THE INCREDIBLE
NUMBERS OF OUR HHS TEAM WHO'VE
BEEN WORKING TIRELESSLY TO
PROTECT THE HEALTH AND WELL
BEING OF ALL AMERICANS. BEFORE
COVERING TODAY'S TOPIC I WANT
TO MENTION A MAJOR MILESTONE
FOR GLOBAL HEALTH YESTERDAY.
THE END OF THE SECOND LARGEST
EBOLA OUTBREAK IN HISTORY IN
THE EASTERN DEMOCRATIC REPUBLIC
OF THE CONGO. WE CAN GRADUALLY
BELIEVES GOVERNMENT AND ALL OF
THE HEALTH CARE WORKERS AND
COMMUNITY MEMBERS INVOLVED SOME
OF WHOM I HAD THE CHANCE TO
MEET AND THANK IN THE DRC LAST.
UNDER PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES WILL. PLAY A BIGGER ROLE
IN THIS MAJOR PUBLIC HEALTH
VICTORY THAN ANY OTHER SINGLE
NATION. AND NOW THANKS TO THE
PRESIDENT THE VICE PRESIDENT'S
LEADERSHIP ON THE HARD WORK OF
OUR TEAM AMERICA HAS NEVER BEEN
READY OR TO COMBAT COVID
NINETEEN. WE BUILD UP OUR
READINESS UNDER THE STRATEGY WE
DEVELOPED TO ADDRESS SURGES
SAVE LIVES IN IN TIME TO FEED
THE VIRUS. WERE MUCH STRONGER
POSITION TO SUPPORT STATE'S
HOSPITALS AND INDIVIDUALS AS
THEY FIGHT BACK. THERE SIX
PARTS TO THE STRAP.
SURVEILLANCE TESTING
CONTAINMENT HEALTH CARE
CAPACITY THERAPEUTICS AND
VACCINES. FIRST WE'VE BEEN
STRENGTHENING SURVEILLANCE SO
THAT WE CAN BE AWARE OF AND
RESPOND TO SURGES THAT MEANS
FOR INSTANCE BEING ABLE TO
TRACK MORE CASES AMONG YOUNGER
AMERICANS THAT WE NEVER WOULD
HAVE CAUGHT EARLIER IN THE
PANDEMIC. SACK WE HAVE THE
WORLD'S GREATEST TESTING
CAPABILITY IS ENABLING US TO
CONFIRM THE PRESENCE OF THE
VIRUS WHEN IT CROPS UP. AND
WE'RE CONFIDENT THAT CAPACITY
WILL CONTINUE TO RISE IN THE
COMING MONTHS. THIRD STEP TO
BUILDING CAPACITY TO TRACK AND
CONTAIN OUTBREAKS OF THE VIRUS.
WITH FEDERAL HELP MANY STATES
OF SUBSTANTIALLY EXPANDED THEIR
OWN CAPABILITIES AND WE'RE
DEPLOYING KNOWLEDGEABLE
EXPERIENCED CDC AND HHS PUBLIC
TEAMS TO THE AREAS BEING
INCREASES. WITH AGE YES
COMMUNITY TESTING AND COMMUNITY
BASED INTERVENTIONS. FOR
HELPING HEALTH CARE SYSTEM
SECURE FISHING CAPACITY ON
SUPPLIES WITH DRAMATIC EX
DRAMATICALLY EXPANDED AMERICAN
MANUFACTURING OF PP AND THE FDA
HAS AUTHORIZED NEW TECHNOLOGIES
TO SUPPLIES EQUIPMENT FOR RE
USE. WE SPOKE WITH HOSPITALS
AND STATES THAT ARE BUILDING UP
THEIR OWN PP RESERVES MANY OF
THEM GETTING UP TO SIXTY OR
NINETY DAYS OF SUPPLIES.
THROUGH THE STRATEGIC NATIONAL
STOCKPILE WE HAVE FAR MORE
VISIBILITY INTO THE SUPPLY
NEEDS ACROSS THE COUNTRY
INCLUDING CENTRALIZED
COORDINATION CAPABILITIES THAT
WOULD BACKED JUST A FEW SHORT
MONTHS AGO. VISITING HEALTH
CARE PROVIDERS AROUND THE
COUNTRY I'VE SEEN HOW THEY'RE
ADAPTING TO BRING PATIENTS
BACK. WELL TAKING APPROPRIATE
PRECAUTIONS. BECAUSE HOSPITALS
ARE READY TO GET BACK TO
BUSINESS WHILE MAINTAINING THE
READINESS FOR COVID NINETEEN.
THE FIFTEENTH ALLEN'S OF THIS
STRATEGY- THANKS TO THE
PRESIDENT'S OPERATION WARP
SPEED. WE NOW PROMISING
THERAPEUTICS THAT ARE
BENEFITING TENS OF THOUSANDS OF
AMERICAN PATIENTS AND IN ALL
LIKELIHOOD OF ALREADY SAVED
THOUSANDS OF LIVES. WE'VE I
DON'T KNOW TWO VERY IN
PHARMACEUTICAL. RUN THAT'S A
BEER AND DEXAMETHASONE
DEXAMETHASONE AS OF TODAY WE'VE
ALLOCATED MORE THAN A HUNDRED
TWENTY THOUSAND COURSES OF RUM
DESPEGAR TO ALL OF THE FIFTY
STATES WE'VE ADDED
DEXAMETHASONE OF VERY LOW COST
AIR RIGHT TO ARCS AND GOT TONS.
AND IT'S REALLY COOL TO A
CERTAIN. SOME PLACES WOULD HAVE
SIMILAR IMMUNOLOGICAL EFFECTS.
ANOTHER PROMISING THERAPEUTIC
CONVALESCENT PLASMA HAS BEEN
USED TO TREAT MORE THAN TWENTY
FIVE THOUSAND AMERICANS AND
NEARLY THREE THOUSAND SITES
ACROSS THE COUNTRY. THERE ARE
NO CERTAINTIES IN SCIENCE BUT
WITH MORE THAN ONE HUNDRED AND
FORTY CLINICAL TRIALS UNDERWAY
IN THE U. S. IT'S A PRETTY SAFE
BET THAT MORE GOOD NEWS ON
THERAPEUTICS IS ON THE WAY. AND
ON THE WAY SEN. FINALLY WE'VE
BEEN AT LARGE INVESTMENTS TO
SUPPORT THREE DIFFERENT
MANUFACTURING CABINETS ALL THE
WAY THROUGH TO MANUFACTURING.
THESE CANDIDATES ARE NOW IN
HUMAN CLINICAL TRIALS SOME WITH
THE POTENTIAL TO START
DELIVERING SAFE AND EFFECTIVE
DOSES. BEFORE THE END OF THE
YEAR AND WILL BE ADDING SUPPORT
FOR SEVERAL MORE CANDIDATES.
WERE EXPANDING MANUFACTURING
CAPACITY IN ALL BE MAKING THE
VIALS NEEDLES AND SYRINGES WE
MADE. OUR CAPABILITIES HAVE
GROWN EXPONENTIALLY IN THE TIME
ALLOWED BY THE PATRIOTIC
SACRIFICE. THE AMOUNT PEOPLE.
WILL AGREE OF PIRATES DR
SENATE. AND MUCH MORE DATA WITH
WHICH TO MODEL IT. WITHOUT
DOUBT AS YOU'VE HEARD TODAY WE
CAN FOCUS ON LOCAL TRENDS. WE
HAVE SOME VERY CONCERNING HOT
SPOTS AND WE CAN TRACK WHEN
OTHER HOT SPOTS EMERGE AS WE
EXPECT THEY MAY. WE'RE FOCUSED
ON THE STATE'S IN THE COUNTIES
WITHIN THOSE STATES JUST 3% OF
COUNTIES THAT REPRESENT
HOTSPOTS. IT'S IMPORTANT FOR
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE TO BE AWARE
OF THIS VARIABILITY IN
VARIATION ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
AMERICANS NEED TO UNDERSTAND
THEIR LOCAL TRANS BECAUSE WE
WANT TO HELP PEOPLE MAKE THE
RIGHT DECISIONS FOR THEMSELVES.
MAKING DECISIONS FOR YOURSELF
HAS TO BE BASED ON THREE AXES
OF RISK AS OUR SURGEON GENERAL
TAUGHT US IN MARCH. YOU WANT TO
ASSESS WHERE YOU ARE. WHO YOU
ARE AND WHO YOU LIVE WITH AND
WHAT ACTIVITY YOU'RE THINKING
ABOUT DOING. THERE ARE THERE
ARE GRADATIONS OF RISK WITHIN
EACH OF THESE AXES GOING TO AN
OUTDOOR RESTAURANT IN MONTANA
IS A GREAT DEAL DIFFERENT FROM
A CROWDED INDOOR BAR IN
HOUSTON. WHEN YOU INTERACT WITH
FEWER PEOPLE IN ACTIVITY. WHEN
YOU INTERACT WITH THEM FOR A
SHORTER PERIOD OF TIME YOUR
RISK IS REDUCED. AND
INDIVIDUALS CAN BALANCE THESE
CALL. FACTORS WHAT I'VE LATER
TODAY IS REMARKABLE PROGRESS
BUT THE PRESIDENT'S
ADMINISTRATION IN A PARTICULAR
CREDIT. TO THE TEAM HERE AT
HHS. WE'VE GOT A LOT OF WORK
AHEAD OF US BUT AMERICANS CAN
BE CONFIDENT THAT WE HAVE A
ROCK SOLID FOUNDATION TO HELP
US GET SAFELY BACK TO WORK.
BACK TO SCHOOL BACK TO WORSHIP.
AND BACK TO HEALTH. WELL WE
TACKLE SURGES OF THE VIRUS
WHERE THEY OCCUR. THANKS TO
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S LEADERSHIP
WE'VE GOT THE CAPABILITIES THE
KNOWLEDGE AND THE STRATEGY TO
PROTECT AMERICAN LIVES
LIVELIHOODS THIS TIME. AND ERIC
IT SHOULD FEEL PROUD OF THAT.
THANK YOU MR VICE PRESIDENT. I
WANTED TO ADD SOME COMMENTS.
ONCE AGAIN I WANT TO STRESS AND
THANK ALL AMERICANS- TO EMBRACE
THE IMPORTANCE OF SOCIAL
DISTANCING RECOMMENDATIONS. TO
SLOW THE SPREAD OF COVID AS
I'VE SAID BEFORE. WE'RE NOT
DEFENSELESS THESE ARE IN FACT
VERY POWERFUL WEAPONS AND IT'S
OUR COLLECTIVE RESPONSIBILITY.
TO RECOMMIT OURSELVES TO PUT
THEM INTO ROUTINE PRACTICE.
AGAIN THE STAKES SIX FEET APART
FROM EACH OTHER AS MUCH AS
POSSIBLE TO WEAR FACE COVERINGS
WHEN WE'RE IN PUBLIC AND THE
PRACTICE VIGOROUS HAND HYGIENE.
AND TO COMMIT TO DO SO AS WE'VE
HEARD TODAY TO DO OUR PART TO
PROTECT THE VULNERABLE. I ALSO
WANT TO APPEAL TO THE
MILLENNIALS AND THOSE THAT ARE
UNDER FORTY. IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT THAT THIS GROUP.
REALLY COMMIT THEMSELVES TO
THESE PRACTICES TO PROTECT
THOSE AT RISK. AND IT'S NOT
JUST THE ELDERLY THAT ARE RISK.
MANY OF US MAY HAVE FRIENDS AND
COLLEAGUES THAT ARE YOUNGER
THAT MAY NOT- ADVERTISE THEIR
UNDERLYING COMORBIDITIES- HELLO
THAT IS THE CASE WOULD BE WITH
SAID TYPE ONE DIABETES. ANOTHER
NINE. DEFICIENCIES SO AGAIN
ASKING THIS TEAM. MILLENNIALS
AND YOUNGER PEOPLE IN THIS
COUNTRY TO COME AND COMMIT
THEMSELVES I AGREE WITH THE
INVESTOR BURKE'S- WE'RE VERY
THANKFUL THAT THE GROUP IS NOW
COMING FORWARD. AND TO GET
TESTED BUT I ALSO WANT THIS
GROUP TO PUT INDIVIDUAL IN
PRACTICE- THE IMPORTANCE OF OUR
SOCIAL DISTANCING. THE ONE
THING THAT I WANTED TO STRESS
THOUGH IS THAT. THERE ARE
DIFFERENCES. IN WHAT WE'RE
EXPERIENCING TODAY THAN WHAT WE
ALL EXPERIENCE IN MARCH AND
APRIL AND MAY. AND ONE OF THE
THINGS I WANT US TO FOCUS ON IS
NOT THE CASES PER SE. BUT THE
CONSEQUENCES THE IMPACT OF
THOSE CASES. IT WASN'T LONG AGO
PROBABLY WITHIN TWO MONTHS AGO
IT'S HARD TO BELIEVE I DON'T
THINK MANY PEOPLE REALIZED THAT
27% OF ALL DEATHS. THAT
OCCURRED IN THE UNITED STATES
ACTUALLY DIED OF PNEUMONIA.
THERE WAS A PNEUMONIA COULD
HAVE BEEN INFLUENZA COULD HAVE
BEEN COVID 27% ONE FOR OF ALL
THE DEATHS IN THE UNITED
STATES. JUST TWO MONTHS AGO WAS
FINE THE MONA. I'M HAPPY TO SAY
TODAY THE TESTIMONY INTONATIONS
BACKED THE BASELINE ABOUT SEVEN
PERCENT. THE BIG DIFFERENCE A
LOT OF THOSE PNEUMONIAS THAT
WE'RE DYING WE'RE ACTUALLY
COVID INFECTED INDIVIDUALS THAT
WORK- THE ELDERLY NURSING HOMES
AND INDIVIDUALS WITH CO
MORBIDITIES. WE ARE SEEN
DESPITE THESE INCREASE CASES WE
HAVE SEEN A PROGRESSIVE DECLINE
IN DEATHS. OF THE LAST SAY TWO
WEEK AVERAGE DEATH IN THE
UNITED STATES NOW IS AROUND SIX
SIX HUNDRED AND FIFTY AND AS
YOU HEARD THE VICE PRESIDENT
WASN'T LONG AGO. AT WEAVER WAS
INTO FIVE. THOUSAND INDIVIDUALS.
SO I THINK IT'S CRITICAL THAT
WE CONTINUE TO FOCUS ON. ON ON
BACKED THE CONSEQUENCES IN THIS
PART OF THAT WHY. IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT WE CONTINUE ALSO
TO LOOK FORWARD TO HOW WE DEAL
WITH IN PAIN CONTROL THE COVID
PERFECTION BUT AS WE ALSO. THE
CONSEQUENCES OF THE IMPACT IT'S
HAD ON EDUCATION. THREE
QUARTERS INNER CALLING ME IN
BUSINESS. AGAIN IT CLOSE I WANT
TO JUST RE RE RE RE EMPHASIZE
HOW IMPORTANT FOR NOW. FOR
INDIVIDUALS TO REALLY THINK
SERIOUSLY AS TONY SAID ABOUT.
THE RESPONSIBILITY TO OTHERS
THAT WE HAVE BECAUSE THIS
INFECTION PATHOGENS REALLY DOES
HAVE THE CAPACITY TO CAUSE
QUITE SERIOUS ILLNESS IN
INDIVIDUALS AT HIGH RISK IN IN
BRITAIN BRACE OUR NATION'S.
RECOMMENDATIONS OF DEVICES AND-
PUT UP AGAIN THAT WE HAVE FOR
ALL FACES OF REOPEN AMERICA.
AGAIN I ALSO WANT TO THANK THE
GROUP FOR STATE FORWARD IN
GETTING TESTED CLEARLY WHAT
WE'RE SEEING NOW IS THIS AGE
GROUP IS MUCH MORE LIKELY TO BE
A SYMPTOMATIC. AND AGAIN. TO
MAKE THE COMMITMENT TO DO THEIR
PART TO PROTECT THOSE OF US.
THAT WHETHER WE'RE YOUNG OR OLD
HAVE A COMORBIDITY AND WOULD BE
MORE VULNERABLE TO SERIOUS
ILLNESS FROM THIS FARCE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. AFTER A FAILED
QUESTIONS. YES PLEASE ON THE
EXPRESS THE CODE IN THE TASK
FORCE ARE STRESSING THE
IMPORTANCE OF- AND ALSO THE
THREAT OF CROWDS GET YOUR
CAMPAIGN. THE MASSIVE RALLY.
BACK AND YOU KNOW EVEN ABOUT
THE AFTER YOU BEEN LARGE CROWDS.
WHITE FIVE DIFFERENT WELL DID
THE FREEDOM OF SPEECH THE RIGHT
TO PEACEABLY ASSEMBLE AS
ENSHRINED IN THE CONSTITUTION
OF THE UNITED STATES AND- WE
HAVE AN ELECTION COMING UP THIS
FALL. AND OF PRESIDENT TRUMP
AND I BELIEVE THAT TAKING
PROPER STEPS SINCE RECRUITED
SCREENING AT RECENT EVENTS AND
OTHERS. GIVING PEOPLE THE VERY
BEST COUNCIL THAT WE HAVE WE
STILL WANT TO GIVE PEOPLE THE
FREEDOM TO PARTICIPATE IN THE
POLITICAL PROCESS AND- I WE
RESPECT THAT. I WAS- I WAS
PLEASED TO SEE THAT NOW OF THE
BETTER PART OF A WEEK AND SINCE
WE WERE IN OKLAHOMA I THINK
THEIR POSITIVITY RATE- IS
ACTUALLY DECLINED AS OF TODAY
AND THAT'S GREAT TEST. THE FACT
THAT THE- PEOPLE ARE USING
COMMON SENSE THEY'RE BEING
RESPONSIBLE THEY KNOW AND
UNDERSTAND WHAT'S HAPPENING
COMMUNITY IN WHICH THEY LIVE.
IN OUR EMPHASIS TODAY IS REALLY
TO SAY THAT- WE THINK IT'S MOST
HELPFUL IF THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
UNDERSTAND THAT. WHAT WE'RE
SEEING ACROSS THE SOUTH TODAY
IS REALLY OUTBREAKS THEIR
OUTBREAKS THAT ARE IN SPECIFIC
COUNTIES IN SOME CASES THEIR
OUTBREAKS THAT ARE SPECIFIC
COMMUNITIES- A. ON WE'VE
SEARCHED POLICE PERSONNEL EIGHT
THIS. PERSONNEL I DIDN'T BEFORE
BUT THREE WEEKS AGO WHEN BEING
SIMILAR TO THE NORTH. END OF
NOVEMBER WE SENT PERSONNEL. IN
THOSE PLACES WE SEEM DECLINING
NUMBER BEGINNING ON BOTH OF
THOSE STATES SO. IMPORTANT
THING IS IT NOT NOT ONE SIZE
FITS ALL. THE OVERALL GUIDANCE
TO EVERY AMERICAN TO PRACTICE
GOOD HYGIENE TO PRACTICE ON THE
MEASURES THAT WE RECOMMENDED AT
HOME AND AT WORK- STAND BUT-
BUT OUR FOCUS TODAY IS TO MAKE
SURE THAT IN THOSE AREAS IN THE
COUNTRY WERE SEEING IS
DIFFICULT. NOT ONLY IN RECENT
K. RECENT POSITIVITY LEVEL THAT
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE KNOW JUST.
HOW IMPORTANT IT IS TO LISTEN
TO WHAT THEIR STATE. AND LOCAL
HEALTH OFFICIALS ARE DIRECTING
THEM TO DO. WHICH IS LIKE THE
WEARING OF MASKS THAT'S KIND OF
BECOME A POLITICAL STATEMENT OR
I GUESS. THE DECISION NOT TO
WEAR A MASK ARE YOU CONCERNED
ABOUT THAT- AND IS THERE A
MESSAGE THAT YOU WOULD LIKE TO
SEND THE PEOPLE ABOUT THE
IMPORTANCE OF. MASS WELL WE-
THANK THAT WE OF THE FIRST
PRINCIPLE IS THE PEOPLE THE
STATE LOCAL AUTHORITIES. MAY I
HAVE TO TELL YOU PRESIDENT
TRUMP AND I COULDN'T BE MORE
GRATEFUL FOR THE PARTNERSHIP WE
FORGE WITH GOVERNORS AROUND THE
COUNTRY- I SPOKE TO- THE
GOVERNOR OF FLORIDA ARIZONA
TEXAS JUST WITHIN THE LAST
TWELVE HOURS. AND I TOLD THEM
THAT FROM THIS PODIUM TODAY WE
WOULD REMIND THEIR CITIZENS TO.
TAKE HEED OF THE GARDENS ON THE
DIRECTION OF STATE AND LOCAL
OFFICIALS. IN SOME CASES
THERE'S A STATEWIDE GUIDANCE
WITH REGARD TO FACIAL COP ON
SCENE WITH REGARD. ON TWO. A
VINCENT GATHERINGS IN OTHER
CASES OR SPECIFIC COUNTY WHAT
SHOULD. I DO. THE LEADERSHIP IN
THE LOCAL COMMUNITY AND HEAR
THAT GUIDES WITH THAT HAVE TO
DO WITH. FACE COVERINGS WHETHER
HAVE TO DO WITH THE SIZE OF
GATHERINGS AND UP WILL CONTINUE
TO REINFORCE THAT MESSAGE.
PLEASE. LOCAL WHAT IS THE
CORRELATION BETWEEN THE SPY
CASE THAT WE'RE SEEING IN
STATES LIKE TEXAS AND FLORIDA.
AND THE WEIGHT OF STATE TABLE
TO READ THEIR RE OPENING WAS IT
TOO MUCH TOO SOON. SECONDLY I
WANT TO ASK THE DOCTOR FELT SHE
IN AN INTERVIEW THAT. QUOTE
SOMETHING IS NOT WORKING. WHAT
ISN'T WORKING AND DID YOU ALL
IN YOUR MEETING TODAY COME UP.
WITH A PLAN TO FIX WHATEVER IS.
WELL LET ME RISK FIRST ATTACKS
OF FELT SHE ADDRESSES WELL DR
BROOKS MAY. AS WELL I THINK
THERE WERE BE ATTEMPT FOR TO
LOOK AT THE- OF THE SUN BELT
STATES THAT HAVE BEEN RE
OPENING AND PUTTING PEOPLE BACK
TO WORK- IN THE INSIDE. THE
REAL HAS TO DO WHAT WE'RE
SEEING IN THE LAST WEEK OR SO
BUT- FRANKLY IN THE CASE OF
EACH STATE'S THEY RE OPENED. IN
SOME CASES ALMOST TWO MONTHS
AGO. END AND THEIR TEST CASES
OTHER NEW CASES THAT FROM
TESTING WAS SLOW AND STEADY
THEIR POSITIVITY RATE. WAS LOW-
WHAT WHAT WE'RE OBSERVING-
TODAY AND I'VE HEARD THIS FROM
FLORIDA I'VE HEARD THIS FROM
TEXAS. AND SOME OTHER STATES-
ON THE SUNBELT. IS THAT- WE'RE
SEEING MORE AND MORE YOUNG
PEOPLE. UNDER THE AGE OF THIRTY
FIVE WHO ARE TESTING POSITIVE
IN MANY CASES THEY HAVE NO
SYMPTOMS- BUT THEY'RE COMING
FORWARD- IN CONFIRMING THAT
THEY THAT THEY HAVE CONTRACTED
AT THE CORONAVIRUS. OUT WE'RE
WORKING WITH THE STATE'S YOU
SPEAK ABOUT OUR PLAN WE'VE GOT
WE'VE GOT CDC PERSONNEL IN IN
EVERY IN THE YEAR. WE'RE SORRY
RECEIVE PURSE. TWO EACH OF THE
STATE'S HELP THEM ON. THE DATA
IS SUGGEST I KNOW THE GUY OF
THE TECH. ANNOUNCED US A NEW
THIS MORNING WHICH WE FULLY.
SUPPORT BUT WHAT WE CONTINUE TO
DO IS GIVE GIVE OUR STATE
LEADERSHIP THE VERY BEST
INFORMATION THE VERY BEST
COUNCIL. ON THAT WE HAVE END.
END END IF THERE'S ONE MESSAGE
THAT- COMES THROUGH TODAY I
HOPE IT IS IT IS SAYING TO
YOUNGER AMERICANS THESE
STATEMENTS IN IN THESE THINGS
AND- THE- OF. THEY ARE ARE A
BIG PART OF THE NUMBER THAT WE
SEEING IN NEW CASES AND WHILE
THERE MAY NOT BE A SIGNIFICANT
THREAT. THE SERIES HEALTH OUT
COME TO THEM I KNOW OF NO YOUNG
PERSON I GOT I GOT THREE TWENTY
SOMETHINGS IN MY IMMEDIATE
FAMILY- NO YOUNG PERSON EVER
WANNA INADVERTENTLY EXPOSE. ON
MOM AND MOTHER GRANDFATHER
SOMEONE WHOSE VULNERABLE. TO
SERIOUS RESULTS AND SO ALERTING
THEM THAT THERE'S BEEN SPREAD
AMONG THAT AGE GROUP URGES TO
TAKE OUT A MESSAGE AND HE WOULD.
ANDREW CORRECT. CONTINUE TO DR
YOU DID YOU WANT TO. SO WHAT
AMID BY WHAT IS WORK. IN THE IS
NOT ANY FAULT OR ANY
INSTITUTION FOR IS THAT WHAT
WE'RE DEALING RIGHT NOW IS
COMMUNITY SPREAD IN THE CONTEXT
OF A SUBSTANTIAL PROPORTION. OF
THE PEOPLE GETTING INFECTED. DO
NOT KNOW THEY'RE INFECTED
THEY'RE NOT SYMPTOMATIC THERE A
SYMPTOMATIC INDIVIDUALS. THE
CLASSIC PARADIGM OF
IDENTIFICATION ISOLATION AND
CONTACT TRACING TO ACTUALLY
CONTAIN THAT. IS VERY DIFFICULT
TO MAKE THAT LITTLE CIRCLE THIS.
SUPER UPON THAT THE FACT THAT.
WITH IDENTIFICATION ISOLATION
CONTACT TRACING OFTEN THE DOTS
ARE NOT CONNECTED IF YOU GET ON
THE PHONE AND TALK TO PEOPLE
WHO ARE IN SOME OF THESE
COMMUNITIES YOU FIND A LOT OF
IT IS MY PHONE. AND WHEN IT'S
BY PHONE THE PEOPLE DON'T EVEN
TO TALK ON I THINK IS A
GOVERNMENT REPRESENTATIVE IF
YOU LIVE IN A COMMUNITY THAT IS
MOSTLY BROWN OR BLACK THE- WAY
SHE MAYBE SEVEN. OF THEM. TWO
TO. YOU AGAIN IF I CAN'T. BUT
YOU DON'T I THEM BECAUSE YOU
DON'T HAVE TO ISOLATE. THAT IS
WHY NOT WORKING SO WHAT WE'RE
GONNA DO WHEN WE DOING. IN
YOU'RE GONNA BE HEARING A THIS.
YOU KNOW FLOODING THE CITY'S
FLOODING THE AREA OF THE CAN.
TO GET HEALED WHAT'S THERE
PARTICULARLY AMONG THE A
SYMPTOM. SO IN OTHER WORDS IT'S
A PASSWORD SHIFT BECAUSE WE
DEAL WITH YOUNG PEOPLE. PEOPLE
ARE GOING TO BE A SYMPTOM. AND
PEOPLE WHO ARE GETTING. NEEDED
TO ADDING. HELP READING NO DO
IDENTIFY ISEL CON CHASE THAT'S
WHAT I MEANT WELCOME. HE OKAY
AFTER FIVE YEARS OF WORK
STRAIGHT. BUT I DIDN'T I DOES
NOT HAVE FINISHED AT. SAYS NEW
MEXICO AND ARIZONA IS TO NOT
ONLY MEET WITH THE STATE LOCAL
HEALTH OFFICIALS BUT TO MEET
WITH THE COMMUNITY GROUPS SO
THE COMMUNITY. CAN SUPPORT
COMMUNITY SPECIFIC MESSAGING
PUBLIC HEALTH MESSAGING WHEN
YOU JUST KEEP SAYING THE SAME
THING OVER AND OVER AGAIN AND
THAT PEOPLE GET TONE DEAF TO
IT. IT'S BECAUSE IT'S NOT
TAILORED SPECIFIC CIRCUMSTANCES
AND DUMPS THAT IT'S RESONATING
IN THEIR LIVES. WE'VE HAD TO DO
THIS ACROSS THE WORLD I'M DONE
THIS OVER AND OVER AGAIN FOR
HIV TB AND MALARIA AT THE
CENTER OF THIS PAST DICK. D.
AND THE COMMUNITY HELP US. IT'S
FASTER. ABOUT FIVE. HOUSE THE
LADY AND THE AND HOW WE CAN
REALLY GO THE COME AND SUPPORT
THAT RESPONSE AT A VERY LOCAL
ON GROUND LEVEL. STARTED AS
WE'RE VERY MUCH FACILITY BASED
IN WE KNOW FACILITIES CARRY US
A LONG WAY. BUT IF WE WANT TO
CHANGE THE TRANSMISSION RATES
IN THESE METROS IN SPECIFIC
COMMUNITIES AND CIVIC PARTS OF
THOSE MATTRESS WE'VE GOT A WALK
WALK. SIDE BY SIDE WITH OUR
COMMUNITY LEADERS COMMUNITY
GROUPS NO BUT TRANSLATE OUR
SCIENTIFIC DOGMA AND
INFORMATION DOWN TO. PEOPLE
WILL UNDERSTAND IT HERE AT ACT
I KNOW WHEN THEY HEAR IT AND
UNDERSTAND IT THEY WILL ACT ON
IT AND SO THAT'S HOW THAT WHEN
YOU ASK WHAT'S GOING TO BE
DIFFERENT. THAT IS ALREADY
STARTED AND IT'S GOING TO BE
DIFFERENT. JUST JUST ON THE
EDGE OF THAT EXACTLY. WHAT WE
DID WITH HIV. THIRTY YEARS AGO.
WE GOT THE COMMUNITY INVOLVED
IN HELPING US TO HELP REACH AND
I THINK IT'S VERY IMPORTANT ON
THE SCHOOL. DR BURKE SAID AND
THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT'S BEING
POLL. DO NO THE COMMUNITY WHO
IN THE COMMUNITY FOR THE
COMMUNITY TRUSTS. YEAH ABOUT
RIGHT HERE. THE DEATH RATE TO
GO UP IN THE NEXT THREE OR FOUR
WEEKS JUST LIKE WE'RE SEEING
THE RATE OF INFECTION GO UP NOW.
WELL OUR THIS IS NOT THE CASE
WE SEEN AS YOU AS YOU NOTED WE
SEEN A PRECIPITOUS DECLINE IN
FATALITIES AND AGAIN ON AUG.
ONE IS TOO MANY. WE GRIEVE THE
LOSS OF EVERY AMERICAN LIFE BUT
THE FACT THAT TWO MONTHS AGO WE
HAD LOST TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED
AMERICANS IN A SINGLE DAY IN
TWO DAYS THIS WEEK I WAS LESS
THAN THREE HUNDRED. ERIC IS A
TESTAMENT. TWO ARE HEALTH CARE
WORKERS TO ALL THE MEDICINES
THAT SECTOR IS ARE JUST
DESCRIBED BEING BEING AVAILABLE
IN ALL FIFTY STATES IT
TESTAMENT- TO THE EFFORTS OF
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE MY HOPE IS
WE CONTINUE TO ENGAGE THE WILL
CONTINUE THOSE NUMBER ONE.
REASONS THIS BECAUSE- THIS
POINT WHEN WE LOOK AT OUR
LOSSES- ROUGHLY TWO POINT 5% OF
ALL OF OUR LOSSES IT TOOK PLACE
IN PEOPLE UNDER THE AGE OF
TWENTY FIVE. YOUNGER AMERICANS
IN EACH CASE- OR AT LEAST 90%
OF THE CASES THEY WERE PEOPLE
WITH. WITH PRE EXISTING
CONDITIONS UNDERLYING
CONDITIONS THAT CONTRIBUTED. TO
THE SAD OUTCOME. AND SO. AS WE
SEE THAT IN FLORIDA AND IN
TEXAS THEY REPORTED TO US THAT
HALF OR EVEN MORE THAN HALF OF
THE NEW CASES THAT ARE SHOWING
UP. EVERY DAY. OUR UNDER THE
AGE OF THIRTY FOR YOUNGER
AMERICANS IN MOST CASES A
SYMPTOMATIC. OUR HOPE IS THAT-
THOSE YOUNGER HEALTHIER
AMERICANS LIKE MOST HAVE
ALREADY WILL CONTINUE- TO GO
THROUGH THE COURT VIRUS WILL
RECOVER. BUT OUR MESSAGE TODAY
AT WE'VE SPENT SO MUCH ENERGY
IN THE LAST FOUR MONTHS
PROTECTING THE MOST VULNERABLE.
DEPLOYED TESTING RESOURCES
WHICH SUPPORTED STATE'S
EFFORTS. ON THE STATE'S ACROSS
THE COUNTRY IN THE LAST MONTH
OF ANSWERED OUR CALL TO TEST
ALL THE RESIDENTS OF THE
NURSING HOMES. TO SET UP A
PLANNED TEST. ALL OF THE STAFF-
ON A REGULAR BASIS- WEEK WE
NEED TO PROTECT MOST VULNERABLE
AND WE WANT TO MESSAGE GOING.
THE AMERICANS PARTICULARLY
THOSE ALONG THE SUNBELT IN
THESE COUNTIES WHERE WE SEE.
NEW CASES ON THE RISE
POSITIVITY ON THE RISE. TO KNOW
THAT WOULD NEED THEM TO DO
THEIR PART TO MAKE SURE TO
PROTECT THE MOST VULNERABLE SO
THAT WE CAN SO THAT WE DON'T
SEE THOSE LOSSES. HONESTLY IT'S
IN THE HANDS OF THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE PARTICULARLY. YOUNG
PEOPLE IN THIS COUNTRY. SURE
DOES DOWN THOUGH LIKE YOU'RE
SAYING DO AS WE SAY NOT AS WE
DO YOU'RE TELLING PEOPLE TO
LISTEN TO LOCAL OFFICIALS BUT
IT ALSO YOU TO FIND LOCAL
HEALTH OFFICIALS TO HAVE AN
EVENT THAT EVEN THOUGH YOU SAY
DIDN'T RESULT IN A SPIKE DOZENS
OF SECRET SERVICE AGENTS DOZENS
OF CAMPAIGNS NOW QUARANTINE
AFTER POSITIVE TESTS AND THEN
IN ARIZONA ON THE HARD HIT
STATES AFTER CHURCH YOUNG
PEOPLE WANT A MASS. THE
CAMPAIGN. IS NOT PART. FROM THE
DOCTOR FOR YOU IT OUT. WELL I
WANT TO REMIND YOU AGAIN THAT
THE- FREEDOM OF SPEECH AND
RIGHT TO PEACEABLY ASSEMBLE
CINTRON AND CONSTITUTIONALLY
KNIGHTED STATES. AND EVEN IN A
HEALTH CRISIS THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE DON'T FORFEIT OUR
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHTS. IN
WORKING WITH STATE OFFICIALS-
AS WE DID IN OKLAHOMA ON AS A-
AS WE DID- IN ARIZONA. WE'RE
CREATING SETTINGS WHERE PEOPLE
CAN CHOOSE TO PARTICIPATE. IN
THE POLITICAL PROCESS AND- AND
WILL CONTINUE TO DO THAT- IT I
THINK IT'S I THINK IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT THAT WE RECOGNIZE.
HOW IMPORTANT. HOW IMPORTANT
FREEDOM AND PERSONAL
RESPONSIBILITY OR TO THIS
ENTIRE QUESTION AND BUT
ALLOWING ALLOWING YOUNGER
AMERICANS ALLOWING AMER YOUNGER
AMERICANS UNDERSTAND
PARTICULARLY IN THE COUNTIES
THAT ARE MOST IMPACTED- THE
UNIVERSALITY IS- THAT- WE'RE
FACING. IN THEIR AGE GROUP WE
THINK IS IMPORTANT BUT LOOK
IT'S SO IMPORTANT. THAT WE
RECOGNIZE. THAT THE- AS WE
ISSUED GUIDANCE TO REOPEN
AMERICA NOW TWO MONTHS AGO AND
NOW IT'S ALL FIFTY STATES ARE
OPENING UP OUR COUNTRY AGAIN
PEOPLE ARE GOING BACK TO WORK.
AMERICAN EVERY DAY LIFE IS
BEING RESTORED KIND OF ONE STEP
ONE DAY. AT A TIME. I THINK
IT'S IMPORTANT THAT WE REMIND
OURSELVES THIS IS NOT A CHOICE
BETWEEN. THE HEALTH OF THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE. AND A STRONG
ECONOMY THERE ARE PROFOUND
HEALTH IMPLICATIONS. TWO THE
LOCKDOWNS THROUGH WHICH WE JUST
PASSED I HEARD IT I HEARD A
STATISTIC NOT LONG AT A AT A S.
FORCE BRIEFING. THE IN ONE
JURISDICTION THERE'D BEEN A 50%
INCREASE IN THE NUMBER OF
PEOPLE PRESENTING AT EMERGENCY
ROOMS HAVING ATTEMPTED SUICIDE.
WE THEREFORE FROM MENTAL HEALTH
ISSUES THERE ARE PROFOUND
ECONOMIC ISSUES PEOPLE NEEDING
TO BE BACK TO WORK. AND SO
WE'RE WE'RE- OUR OBJECTIVE HERE
TODAY IS JUST TO MAKE SURE THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE NOW. IN THIRTY
FOUR STATES. THE CASES ARE.
LARGELY STABLE AND THERE'S NO
COMBINATION OF RISING CASES AND
RISING POSITIVITY RATES THAT'S
A TRIBUTE TO THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE. IN IN THE IN THE
SIXTEEN WHICH WERE FOCUSED ON A
TODAY- BUT WE SIMPLY WANNA WE
WANNA QUIT PARTICULARLY YOUNG
PEOPLE WITH THE KNOWLEDGE OF
THE PART THAT THEY CAN PLAY. IN
STEMMING OTHER PASSING TITLED
NEW CASES NOT BECAUSE THE
CORONAVIRUS REPRESENTS A
SIGNIFICANT THREAT TO THEM.
MOST CASES IT YOUR YOUNGER
AMERICANS BUT BECAUSE WE DON'T
KNOW YOUNGER AMERICAN WOULD
EVER WANT. TO SPREAD THE
CORONAVIRUS TO SOMEONE WHO
WOULD HAVE A SERIOUS OUTCOME-
BUT- I'M GRATEFUL FOR THE TIME
TODAY. WE HOPE THIS IS MY
HEALTH. IN THE- OKAY BACK MORE
INFORMATION AS TIME GOES ON
THANK YOU. THESE MASSIVE RALLY.
AFTER ABOUT THREE.